[Music]
during World War one one of the horrors
of trench warfare was a poisonous yellow
cloud called mustard gas for those
unlucky enough to be exposed it made the
air impossible to breathe burned their
eyes and caused huge blisters on exposed
skin scientists tried desperately to
develop an antidote to this vicious
weapon of war in the process they
discovered the gas was irrevocably
damaging the bone marrow of affected
soldiers halting its ability to make
blood cells despite these awful effects
it gave scientists an idea cancer cells
share a characteristic with bone marrow
both replicate rapidly so could one of
the atrocities of war become a champion
in the fight against cancer researchers
in the 1930s investigated this idea by
injecting compounds derived from mustard
gas into the veins of cancer patients it
took time and trial and error to find
treatments that did more good than harm
but by the end of World War two they
discovered what became known as the
first chemotherapy drugs today there are
more than 100 chemotherapy drugs are
delivered through pills and injections
and use cytotoxic agents which means
compounds that are toxic to living cells
essentially these medicines cause some
level of harm to all cells in the body
even healthy ones but they reserved
their most powerful effects for rapidly
dividing cells which is precisely the
hallmark of cancer take for example
those first chemotherapy drugs which are
still used today and are called
alkylating agents they're injected into
the bloodstream which delivers them to
cells all over the body once inside when
the cell exposes its DNA in order to
copy it they damage the building blocks
of DNA s double helix structure which
can lead to cell death unless the damage
is repaired because cancer cells
multiply rapidly they take in a high
concentration
of alkylating agents and their DNA is
frequently exposed and rarely repaired
so they die off more often than most
other cells which have time to fix
damaged DNA and don't accumulate the
same concentrations of alkylating agents
another form of chemotherapy involves
compounds called microtubule stabilizers
cells have small tubes that assemble to
help with cell division and DNA
replication then break back down when
microtubule stabilizers get inside a
cell
they keep those tiny tubes from
disassembling that prevents the cell
from completing its replication leading
to its death these are just two examples
of the six classes of chemotherapy drugs
we use to treat cancer today but despite
its huge benefits chemotherapy has one
big disadvantage it affects other
healthy cells in the body that naturally
have to renew rapidly hair follicles the
cells of the mouth the gastro intestinal
lining the reproductive system and bone
marrow are hit nearly as hard as cancer
similar to cancer cells the rapid
reproduction of these normal cells means
that they're reaching for resources more
frequently and are therefore more
exposed to the effects of chemo drugs
that leads to several common
side-effects of chemotherapy including
hair loss fatigue infertility nausea and
vomiting doctors commonly prescribed
options to help manage these side
effects such as strong anti-nausea
medications for hair loss devices called
cold caps can help lower the temperature
around the head and constrict blood
vessels limiting the amount of
chemotherapy drugs that reach hair
follicles and once a course of chemo
treatment is over the healthy tissues
that have been badly affected by the
drug will recover and begin to renew as
usual in 2018 alone over 17 million
people worldwide received a cancer
diagnosis but chemotherapy and other
treatments have changed the outlook for
so many just take the fact that up to 95
percent of individuals with testicular
cancer survive it
thanks to advances in treatment even in
people with acute myeloid leukemia an
aggressive blood cancer chemotherapy
puts an estimated 60% of patients under
sixty into remission following their
first phase of treatment researchers are
still developing more precise
interventions that only target the
intended cancer cells
that'll help improve survival rates
while leaving healthy tissues with
reduced harm making one of the best
tools we have in the fight against
cancer even better have you ever
wondered why after many years and
extensive research we still haven't
cured cancer take a closer look at this
particular medical challenge with our
deep dive on the quest for a cure
[Music]